Hey everyone, it's Michael Baltos here
and welcome to the Orderflows market
analysis for Friday, May 5th, 2017.
Again, my name is Michael Baltos. I'm
the founder and trader at
orderflows.com. And Friday was finally
you got a nice move in the S&Ps. It had
been very quiet most of actually going
back into last week and you finally got
some movement uh late in the session on
Friday around the just before the cash
close. You got a nice rally from uh
around the 93 area all the way up to uh
99. So, you know, we're we're coming
right up on, you know, new contract
highs and, you know, we'll see what's
going to happen over the weekend with
the election in in France. Now, the big
thing on the calendar on Friday was
the employment uh data, and you know, it
showed the unemployment rate falling to
a 16-year low of
4.4%. The non-farm payrolls rose better
than expected, 211,000 in April. Now
average average hourly earnings did
manage to rise
about.3% month- on-month but then again
the prior month was
downgraded.1% and the year-on-year rate
actually going into reverse at 2 and a
half%. And why is that important? You
know if you're going to have a healthy
job market you want to see average
hourly earnings increase not uh stay
stagnant. And you know I mean you hear
stories of people making less money now
than they than they made 10 years ago.
So, you know, that that's not a sign of
a healthy economy, but um you know,
hopefully with our new president uh
making America great again, things will
get better. Now, I'm going to talk about
uh you know, order flow and again, you
know, if if you're new to order flow,
what makes orderflow
so you know, so good. I hate to say, you
know, so valuable, but you know, makes
it very useful tool for most traders is
because, you know, orderflow deals with
the reality of the market. you know
what's happening, seeing the market
moving forces in action and to judge,
you know, what's going on rather than,
you know, I said, you know, relying on a
technical indicator that's, you know,
taking an average of prices over a
period of time. You know, with order
flow, you can see what's happening
between the buyers and sellers, this
internal struggle in the market. You
know, that that's what you want to be
looking at to make better trading
decisions. So, uh, before we jump in,
the brief disclaimer. This presentation
is for educationalformational purposes
only and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any type investment
decision. Futures training contains
substantial risk and is not for every
investor. An investor could potentially
lose all or more than initial
investment. Risk capital is money that
can be lost without jeopardizing one's
financial security or lifestyle. Only
risk capital should be used for trading.
Only those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading. Past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results.
The tools I'm going to use in this
presentation is the Orflows Trader,
which is the footprint chart, the Delta
Scalper, and the Delta Surge. The Delta
Surge is free on my website, and you
know, I'm going to show you some
examples of the Delta Surge, where they
work, where they don't work, and explain
to you really how to use it a little bit
better. Um, you know, people have been
downloading it recently off my
website, and sometimes, you know, they
they don't understand how to use it.
It's pretty basic, but still um you know
when you when you download it, first
thing you have to do is restart Ninja
Trader. All these indicators, they run
on Ninja Trader
and you could download a copy of Ninja
Trader for free. I think you still can
and you can run the indicators on there.
They also have a paid version if you
want to route your orders through Ninja
Trader to your
broker. So anyway, um let's jump uh jump
right in. you know, the real interesting
move, the uh the big move in the S&Ps
happened late in the session and you
know, it was the delta scalper, sorry,
the delta surge that you know, really
keyed you in. Now, delta is an aspect of
order flow that um you know, it's one of
the you know, the core
um you know, the core building blocks of
order flow analysis. And what it does is
it tells you, you know, the net buyers
and net sellers, you know, who is in
charge of the market. You know, on a
market moving up, you want to see delta
be positive. On markets moving down, you
expect to see delta be negative. And,
you know,
246, you're coming into the high, you
got buying imbalances one, two
here, and you got the delta surge
kicking off. So, you know, you're going
into the highs. Buyers are really coming
in. Buyers are taking control of this
market. And we make this nice move from
2393 93 and a2 all the way up all the
way up until the close you know at 23
when we hit 23 uh what was the high
90 99 or so u but you know that was that
was a nice move going you know and going
into the close and it was just it was
there you could it's very obvious you
know it doesn't take uh a rocket
scientist to determine this you know
again you know every time you make new
highs or new lows question you should be
asking yourself, are we going to
continue making new highs or make new
lows or, you know, make new lows or are
we going to come off these highs or
lows? In this case, you could by reading
the delta, you have a fairly good uh
accurate depiction of the market that
buyers are taking control of this market
and we're probably going to go higher
and we do. So, you know, that that was
like the to me I think the the biggest
no-brainer trade on
Friday. Okay, the next market I want to
talk about is is crude oil. Crude oil
has been uh pretty volatile the last uh
few trading days and you're getting some
nice nice movements and you know Friday
did not disappoint as well. Now what I'm
going to talk about on crude oil is the
Delta Scalper which is a paid indicator
and Delta Surge which is the free
indicator and you you'll see some
different variations. They read Delta in
different ways and so they're not
they're not the same thing. Um they read
Delta completely different. So then
you're not going to get them kicking off
at the same time. That said, now one of
the basic things, you know, I said
anytime you have any sort of analysis or
indicator and you know you want to buy
or
sell, get confirmation in the bar as
well. You know, if you're looking to
sell, bar should be low. I bar should be
red. You know, it should be a red
candle. You should be closing the bar
that you get an indicator firing off on.
You also should have the price action in
the bar, you You know, so if you're
hitting a sell, right, you should have a
red candle, meaning the bar closed lower
than where it opened. You know, here you
got a sell and the bar closed higher
than where it opened. You know, just
because you have a an indicator fire off
doesn't mean that you have to take the
trade. You know, again, orderflow is not
a red light green light system. Um, you
know, you could
have, you know, a delta signal here like
here you got negative delta with a green
bar. again um you know just because it's
not always going to be negative delta
and a red bar or positive delta and a
green bar. No, perfect for examples here
you got a down bar, you got positive
delta. Here you got negative delta and
an up bar. But you know there's
different ways to read this and you know
if you're taking a signal a sell signal
you don't want the price in the bar to
be trading higher um by the close of
that bar. You know what you want it is
to be uh the bar to close down. So, um,
you know, people they don't understand
that and they just take every signal
that that appears thinking, you know,
it's either going to work or it's not.
Um, you know, that's not right. I mean,
what you want to do is you want you
always everyone says, I got to have an
edge in the market. Well, you're giving
up an edge if you're looking to sell and
the bar itself is closing higher, right?
I mean, why would you do that? I
mean, people do, but uh, you know, then
they write nasty comments about, oh,
your indicators don't work because, you
know, I lost money on this trade. when
you're you not even using your basic uh
analysis of you know filtering out
trades like I said you know I mean
people you know everybody wants
everything done for them but it can't be
done for you up to a certain point you
know you can't be a robot in trading you
know you use your mind right the market
is made up of you know different traders
it's not made up of different robots you
know and you know what you see nowadays
what I see nowadays is a lot of people
coming into trading
that you know
have program I say I don't say
programming experience you know but I
think nowadays you know with computers
you know 30 years ago you didn't have
you know basically computers for trading
but you know people are familiar with
coding and you know what they do is you
know every line of code has to be
correct or the whole thing doesn't work
and you know basically they say oh I got
a sell signal here it didn't work well
they're removing this one step of
analysis. Yeah, sure. I could have had a
program to say only give a sell signal
when the bar turns down or, you know,
only give a buy signal when the bar
turns
higher. But, you know, there's going to
be cases, you know, you got to use your
you got to use your head. I hate to say
use your brain because I had a a senior
person there at JP Morgan. He would
always say that to people said, "Use
your brain." And it was kind of
degrading to hear that. We would we
would joke about it. Um, you know, we
say, "Hey, use your brain." you know,
they would all have this this laugh.
But, uh, you know, it's it's just
another way to call people an idiot.
But, you know, the best computer for
trading is the one that's on your
shoulders. And, you know, if you're not
using that in your analysis,
then you know, you're leaving a big
thing out of it. So, anyway, you know,
so you're going to see times where it
does fail, but you know, if you, you
know, you'll increase your percentages
is taking the trades that make sense.
Not just every single trade. There's
going to be trades that make perfect
sense, trades that are borderline,
trades that make no sense. You know, if
you get rid of the trades that make no
sense, then great. Borderline trades,
yeah, they'll have some, you know,
honestly, there'll be some that you
like, some you don't like, and some that
just make perfect sense. And one of the
ways for me, I think that, you know,
trades make perfect sense is you get the
um, you know, underlying price action of
the bar to confirm the buy or sell
signal.
So, you know, this again is 7:30 on 3
minutes after non-farm payrolls.
Probably wouldn't be taking any trades
anyway. 3 minutes passed. Um, so this is
a sell. This one failed, but again, you
probably shouldn't be taking that. Here
you get a sell. This is the type of sell
you
want. You know, it's coming after a
swing high. You got the down candle in
the bar. I mean, does it come back up
and fail? Yeah. But, you know, this one
at least got a little bit of movement
down then failed rather than just, you
know, completely against you from the
get- go. Um, you know, I know people
that will trail or stop and, you know,
maybe broke even or something on this
trade. I don't know. But, you know, I'
I'd over the long run taking the trades,
you know, the the sells with the red
bars versus sells with green bars is
going to put you ahead. And but again,
you know, non-farm payrolls is a big
number for the markets. And again, you
know, I I don't know if I'd be trading
so close. This is 733,
737. Non-firm payrolls is one of those,
you know, I like to give the market at
least 15 minutes, preferably 30 minutes
to settle down and just sort of go on
it. It's its normal trading courses.
So, excuse me. Anyway, that said, here
you get another sell signal. It got the
red candle. That's what you want. Next
bar down, next bar up, up, and then back
down again. And then you're just sort of
going sideways here. Now, and you got
the sell signal at 748. It's already
803. So, about 15 minutes. You know, it
it gave you one push lower, another push
lower, now sort of circling back up to
um you know, where the signal occurred.
Then here you get a buy signal, green
bar. That's what you want. You get three
bars up, one bar
down. Again, it's the delta scalper.
Don't be looking for this to be
long-term trades. Reason I called it the
delta sculper is because I was looking
for quick moves based off the
delta here. You get the nice bar down,
but it comes right back up. Just
basically going sideways on you. This is
the delta surge. This green, but it's
coming on a red bar. So, probably not
very good idea to be taking
that even though it just it comes
downward, stops you out, and then makes
the move. You know what I prefer is the
moves like this where it's the green bar
and the delta
surge, excuse me. Then it uh, you know,
comes up, makes new
highs, starts going sideways, sells off
again. Here you got Delta Surge giving a
buy, but it's on a red bar. You know,
it's not going to be very effective. And
it just comes down lower before going up
and making new highs.
This is also the delta surge here also
with the stack buying imbalance. Again,
you get up, you make uh you know, next
bar is up, next bar is up. Then you got
the delta surge scalper giving a sell
here. Comes off. This market's pretty
volatile this
morning. Yeah, you're getting moves, but
they're short-term moves, you know, you
know, over the next bar or
two. Uh any other signals? So, you got
these stacked imbalances. I won't get
into that here. Um, again, yeah, you got
the delta surge this time giving the
cell and this is what you want, right?
You want the red bar. Then you see
you're making a nice move down. This is
the delta scalper here giving you a sell
right up here at the swing high after
this nice move from 4622 all the way up
to
4656. You got a
sell. Come down. You got a buy here and
the Delta Scalper giving a buy. Again,
it's the Delta Scalper. It's not the
Delta long-term trader. So, you should
just be looking for the quick hits in
and out. I know people that do have this
indicator and they've programmed the
trading system around it for quick hits
and trail their stop to get out really
quick. Here's a delta surge given a
sell red bar. That's what you want.
Another delta surge here. a red bar, but
honestly, you'd be short from, you know,
in here. There's no reason to be taking
the next one when you're already
short. This was a nice move. Um, then
you got the Delta Scalper giving a buy
here. Nice little move up. Delta
Scalper, though, here is on a red bar.
That's not where you want to be. Delta
surge rather. That's not what you want
to be taking. You don't want to be
getting long on a bar that's turning
down, closing
negative times. It's 12:00 here. Delta
Scalper given a sell here and you get a
nice few bars move lower. Delta scalper
given a buy. Nothing happens. This one
didn't work out. You saw a lot that did.
Um this one
didn't. And what time is it here? It's
1:00 2:00. Well, that was it there. That
was the crude oil. Okay. Next market is
soybeans. Just so you can see, you know,
how this how these things work and and
same concepts work in different markets.
And soybeans is uh obviously different
than crude oil and different than bonds
and different than S&Ps. But you know
the same concepts apply. Same concepts
apply no matter what you're trading. And
here you have your high in the soybeans.
This is
833. And then you got the delta scalper
giving a sell. Delta surge follows up
with another sell. And you make a nice
move from 981 all the way down to 978
area. Here you got the price rejector
giving a buy. You got a single print.
You got a ratio there. rally back up
towards the high. Don't hit the high.
Got a ratio up there.
Sell. Come down here. You got stack cell
balance and the uh delta surge given a
sell, but it doesn't work out. It just
goes, you know, this one would have
stopped you out. Um again, I'm not just
trying to show you all the times they
work. You know, when they don't work
out, I also want you to see that. Um you
know again you know my my thing is not
necessarily just to uh sell you software
but you know I want to sort of educate
you and show you times where things
don't work out because you know there
are times where not everything uh is
comes up roses. Here you hit the high
again um double you know the high that
you made here earlier. First time you
trade 37 now you trade um you 142 lots
and then you hit it again. You trade 10
lots start coming off. You've got the
delta scalper giving a sell here. You
got a couple of imbalances here. Got the
delta surge with stack. Sorry, you got a
stacked imbalance rather. It's not a
delta surge or anything. This is just a
normal stacked imbalance. And you got a
nice little move here. It happened
really quick though. Uh later you got
the delta surge given a sell and you got
a stacked imbalance and you know we move
from the 979 area 979 and a half area
down to the 976. Pause a little bit.
more selling comes in. You can see it
being picked up here in the delta
surge. Come down into this low. I'll say
low. It's the opening price of the day.
Um 973 and 3/4 and you sort of bounce
around. Got another delta scalper given
a sell here. But again, that's at 108.
The market closes at at 115. So, you
know, this one you probably wouldn't
have been taken cuz it's too close to
the close. But, you know, there were
some nice moves to be had in the beans.
See, this was a nice one. Could got in
979, take it all the way down to at
least 975, 974. That's a nice
move. Now, the other thing again that
that I wanted to talk about, you know,
just really quick on, you know, the
importance of the delta surge, you know,
and how I came up with it in my own
trading was, you know, if you're looking
at minute-based charts, okay, this is
not a minute-based chart. This is a
rangebased chart. And you're just going
sideways here, you know, up, down, up,
down, bearish, bearish, not going
anywhere. But you could see how the
delta is, you know, it's kind of flat in
here. Once - 175, 121, 85, 90. But then
it starts picking up 90 - 90 - 288 -
460. That's how you could see the buyers
are taking control or sorry, rather not
the buyers, the
sellers. The sellers are starting to
dominate this market. And then they they
take over more selling down here. And
you know, that's what you're looking
for. That's that's how um you you get
use out of the Delta surges on a market
that's that's going sideways. Even back
here, right? Look at this. We're trading
basically between um what is that 982
and roughly? So, call it 982 and 98
even. So, about two cent range back and
forth. And then you see it just really
pick up here. Boom. Sellers really come
in here. even got stack cell in a
balance and then it just falls over from
980 all the way down to
974. Um, you know, that's that's
that's the beauty of it. I mean, there's
times it works. This one it didn't work,
honestly. Um, I would have expected more
out of this one, but it just wasn't
happening here. But again, you know, I
want you to see the times where they do
work, times where they don't work. Okay,
so the next market uh I'll talk about
here is the bonds bond market. And you
know, there's some nice trading
opportunities in the bonds this morning.
You had this high up here
uh 15210. The first time you hit it, you
don't have a ratio. You do have a
divergence. Second time you hit it, you
don't have a divergence. You do have a
ratio. And you know, I've talked about
this O2X trade where you have the high
with the ratio. You get the pullback
within um you know, two ticks of that
high to get in this one. You know, if
you listen to me and you did it, you
would have gotten in here because at 08,
you know, it was 08 bid. So if you're
offering at 08, you got this unfinished
business here. So you can see it was
0809. So there was a chance to get
filled and you got a nice move
from sorry this is the high is 08 not
10. Um and then you know from basically
06 all the way down to you know down
here where you can see got your first
buying coming in here at uh you know 24
that area um you know 23. So that was a
nice trade we had. And this is the delta
scalper given sells. So yeah, delta
scalper given a cell, but the bar is
green. So you know, I'm not really
interested. The second one, you know,
this is what you want. You want the
delta scalper to be giving you a cell
and you want the bar to be red. So if
you took this one and your stop is just
right behind here, you'd be stopped out.
But if you took this one, that made
sense. This first one doesn't
necessarily make sense because it's the
red bar or sorry, the green bar. You
want a red bar if you're taking a sell.
you know, you want the price action to
confirm, you know, that's why I didn't
have it programmed in there as something
because one, I didn't think, you know,
people would
be, you know, say silly enough to be
taking trade, you know, taking sells on
bars that are trading higher where they
opened. And two, you know, I still like
to do some analysis. You know, I do
think there should be some analysis on
the trader part. And so this again, you
know, if if you're not doing the O2X, if
you're just taking the Delta Sculper by
itself, you know, it's giving you a nice
sell signal here. And again, it's giving
you a nice uh nice little move down
here, you got the delta sculper buy.
It's a green bar. That's what you want.
And it's giving you a nice little move
there. And we just sort of go sideways
before later in the day. Uh sorry, this
is around, you know, here's 8:13 about
and 40 minutes later, 50 minutes later,
starts selling off. Hit the low.
got the price rejector given a buy, but
it's um you know a divergence, no
ratio. Here was a delta scalper given a
sell. Didn't work out. Um it just would
have went sideways all the way up until
the
close. Okay, this is the Euro currency
and this is the Delta Scalper. Again,
there's three examples, three trades
here. Two worked out, one didn't work
out. And you know this first one, red
bar. That's what you want. Second one,
red bar. That's what you want. You got a
little bit of a move lower before it
turned around and start going back up.
Then here you got a delta scalper, but
it's a big green bar. That's not what
you want. You know, you want this, you
want this. You want the red bars for
cells. You want red bars for cells. Now,
again, I'm just going to just in case,
you know, people would say, "Oh, you
know what? He's only showing times that
it worked. It didn't show signs that
didn't work." This is the Delta search.
again going back until 7 this morning,
you know, just to see um again, you
know, 7:30, you're not going to be
trading it during the non-farm payrolls.
I could show it to you, but the market's
moving super fast. You're not going to
be really trading it at that time.
Here's another example. Delta Scalper
gave a sell, but it's on a green bar.
You know, it's at 706, 25 minutes before
the number came out. Would you be
interested in taking it? Probably not.
But again, it's still it's a green bar.
You shouldn't be interested in taking
it. And this was earlier European
session. Now,
uh, where am I
here? So, let me go back to that time
here. Okay, this is that little grouping
here. Sell, sell, sell. But, this last
one you shouldn't be taking. It's the
green bar. And I'll show you something,
you know, for all of you that are
interested in it. It's a nifty little uh
indicator. Boom. You got your high of
the day. You got a ratio with a
divergence, which is good enough for
taking a sell. You come back up. You
know, you wouldn't have been stopped out
if you taken this trade, but you hit
that high again. So, it's a double top.
This time, you got also a divergence,
but also you got the delta scalper
giving you a sell. And what do you do?
You know, you're at your high of the
day. Really, the first sign here, 37.8,
this ratio, the divergence, single
print, all that is telling you you
should be getting looking to sell
anyway. Come back up here, it's
screaming at you, you know, sell. I mean
that's the beauty of what order flow
does is it it shows you what is
happening in the market and it's up to
you to act on it. You know I mean if you
see things that make perfect sense you
know to me these highs appear make
perfect sense to be getting short on
it's I don't see any reason to be buying
looking for us to keep going higher. You
know even though you you hit the high
you come off start coming back up. I
don't think it's really I don't see any
reason to be going getting a long at
this point. Instead, I get another sign
to be going
short. And what does it do? It sells off
from this high up here at what was that
high? 21 and a half. But realistically,
you know, you could be getting short
somewhere around 19, 18, 19. And you
know, we just just go sideways
to say sideways, but you know, you
didn't get a big move down. I mean, you
traded down to 08, so at least 10 full
ticks in the Euro currency and you just
bounced around sideways um for the rest
of the afternoon and then, you know,
later it did rally. I'll say rally, but
I guess it did um going into the close,
made that new high. But again, you
know, to be sitting here from, you know,
these highs at 10:57, you know,
11:00, it's an hour later, you're just
sort of hanging around, you know, 2
hours later. You get out. You don't sit
there, oh, I'm going to hold it till the
close, waiting for the market to
continue selling off. No, you know, it's
had an hour, it's had two hours to make
the move. It's not going any further.
You get out. You know, I know some
people will I know types of people out
there, they'll send me this chart
saying, "Oh, you know, he gave you a
sell here. I got short and then I got
stopped out up here." you know, why why
are you getting short
at, you know, 11:00 a.m. and you're
holding it? You have all this time where
it's in the money for hours and then,
you know, it's not till 2:00 that it
starts moving against I say moving
against but moving back up to the 20
area and then you're getting stopped out
right on that the extreme close of the
day. You know, if if the market is going
sideways for an hour, it's you know
what's going to happen? Well, you got
two choices. It could either continue
going sideways or it can go against you
or it could go in your favor. So you
got, you know, two out of three choices
that um they're telling you um you know
to to get out. One that it's going to go
sideways some more you know so if it is
might as just get out now or two it
could go against you. you know, yes,
there's one chance out of three that it
can continue going down, but you know,
unless you really see something
outstanding in the order flow or, you
know, anything else, any other reason,
you know, don't sit in the trade. Don't
get married to the trade. But, you know,
some people they do. I mean,
unfortunately, that that's one of the
problems with with traders that they
face is sometimes they don't know when
to get out. But, you know, if you're in
a position and you're not getting any
confirmation that the position is going
to continue in your direction, then you
get out. It's it's not that difficult. I
mean, think of it in real life. You
know, we've all been in relationships
that just aren't working out. At some
point, you got to cut that relationship
and get on with your life. You know, you
don't want to prolong your your
suffering. Um, and the markets are the
same way. you know markets and people
think the market is something rare you
know that you know has its own mind no I
mean the market is made up of people and
their emotions and what happens in your
everyday life is you know also happens
in the markets it's just in different
terms and you know you got to realize
what
those the similarities are to you know
what what is going on in your your
personal life and your everyday life I
mean you know going to the grocery store
making decisions on should you buy
something on sale or not is is basically
price action order flow. So this next
one I'm going to show you is is one of
my other proprietary indicators. It's
the transition and you know transition
is is an indicator
that I created that I used to do the
analysis myself and you know I just
wanted something to show it up on the
screen for me so I could free my mind up
to work on and look at other things. And
you know the reason it's called the
transition is because you know it wants
to find areas where the market is
transitioning from buyers to sellers or
in other words supply market supply
driven market to a demand driven market.
And you know that's why it's called the
transition and wasn't very many signals
on
Friday but here okay you know going back
you can see there's nothing in there. So
you know here just before 8:00 you had a
small buy. This is a mini Dow 100 tick
chart. Hit a buy. Yeah, market went up a
little bit. Nothing special. Came back
down. Then you got this nice sell here.
Immediately shot down. Came back up.
Shot down some
more. I don't think you'd been holding
it all the way up here for it to come
back down. Realistically, you know, look
for the mini
Dow. As soon as it starts going against
you, get out. Um, you know, trail your
stop. Um, nothing in in here. Then late
in the day catches the big move, you
know, from
9:10, you know, all the way up to
basically all the way up to the close.
So that's a nice move there. Even got
this nice little squib of a move.
Nothing special. 910 down to, you know,
below 900 before sort of working its way
back up. But this is really the move
that you want. Okay. Lastly, I'm going
to talk about the buns, German buns
today. Um, and it's it's again, it's
just to reiterate taking trades in
context of the market, right? If you be
looking to buy, you know, look to buy
buy look for reasons to be buying it off
the lows. So here, you know, 811, you've
got the new low of the day. You got
buying and balance, buying balance,
buying balance, stack buying and
balance. Here you got delta surge giving
you a buy as well. You know, those are
the trades you want ideally. Um, you
know, you're buying it there off the
low. You get a little bit of a move, go
sideways on you before you got the delta
scalper giving you a sell. Come down
into low again. And you got the delta
scalper giving you a buy. It's on a now
it's on a dogee bar. You know, again,
it's up to you if you want to take it or
not. You do uh shoot up a bit, then just
sort of go sideways, come back down into
lows. Now, you have the stacked selling
imbalance on the low of the day. Do you
make new lows? Is it a winner? Yes,
technically. I mean, you do make new
lows by about, you know, what is that?
50 uh 54. Get down to 49. So about five
ticks and it's just hanging around there
going sideways on you. So you know is is
it the greatest trade? No, not really.
Um you know again it's it's one of those
things you know try and take trades in
context. Yes, it could go lower. You
know it can go one tick lower and it did
go lower you know by definition or you
know honestly I would expect it to go a
little bit you know I personally I just
find it's got more capacity to go up you
know if you're buying it off the low
than you know selling into the lows. Now
again that doesn't mean that you can't
sell at the lows. You can cuz market can
continue to go lower. But you know read
what you're you know over time you know
look at your trades look how well they
perform. You know are you finding
yourself repeatedly selling into lows or
buying into highs and those trades not
working out or you your trades that have
bigger winners? You know are you buying
it near the lows or selling it uh near
the highs? Again, it's it's Yeah, I saw
a quote, right? There was a quote by
somebody Paul Tudtor Jones. Um,
obviously, everybody's familiar with
him. Let me just dig out the quote if I
could find it. Um, Tudtor Jones, I
believe the very best money is made at
market turns. Everyone says you get
killed trying to pick tops and bottoms,
and you make all your money by playing
the trend in the middle. Well, for 12
years, I've been missing the meat in the
middle, but I've made a ton of money at
tops and bottoms. Again, it's not trying
to pick tops and bottoms. It's trying to
pick when it's turning. You know, those
those are the moves that you could get.
You know, like here we're turning.
You're getting a buy sign a buy signal
here. You here it's turning. You're
getting a buy signal. You know, these
moves have big capacity for movements.
So again, you know, you got to decide,
you know, what kind of trader are you?
Um you again, I'm not saying, you know,
are you trying to pick tops and bottoms?
No, you know, but if the market is
telling you, hey, this is a good buying
opportunity, don't pass it up because
you say, well, I'm not trying to pick
tops and bottoms, you know, I don't want
to do that. Um, you know, if the market
is saying, hey, it's buy it here, idiot.
You buy it. Uh, plain and simple. Um,
what more can I say? So,
anyway, that will conclude it uh for
today. It's been an interesting week.
Again, you know, Sunday, you got the
election in France. It'll be an
interesting uh reopening of Globex, the
electronic session on Sunday night, US
time. And you know, I know uh I'll be uh
I'll say glued to the screen, but you
know, I'll definitely be watching it and
seeing what develops. So to learn more
about orderflow trading and the software
I have, uh visit my website,
orderflows.com. And thanks and have a
good weekend, everyone.